et on vous parle vous avez sans doute
entendu cette proposition il ya quelques
mois du remboursement par la sécurité
sociale de huit séances chez le
psychologue pour tous les français
annonce est donc en septembre par
emmanuel macron a bien cela rentre en
vigueur aujourd'hui mais le dispositif
mon psy est loin de faire l'unanimité on
en parle avec vous il ya siggers bonjour
jean les airs et qui est donc concernée
et comment ça marche surtout alors comme
vous venez de le dire on le découvre
aujourd'hui puisque le site vient
d'ouvrir mais concrètement tous français
à partir de 3 ans je cite qui présente
une souffrance psychique d'intensité
légère ou modérée peut avoir accès à ces
c'est ce remboursement de consultation
psychologique jusqu'à 8 par an en ayant
ce qu'on appelle une orientation d'un
médecin ça veut dire en fait sur
ordonnance d'un médecin traitant
préalablement alors c'est pris en charge
par l'assurance maladie à hauteur de 60%
et ensuite ce sont les complémentaires
santé qui vont prendre le relais le
dispositif se présente sous forme de
site internet ça s'appelle vous l'avez
dit mon psy l'url plus précisément c'est
mon psy point
sante.gouv.fr et vous alliez ils
trouvaient environ 1000 1000 praticiens
volontaires qui ont été sélectionnés par
l'assurance maladie vous allez pouvoir
prendre rendez vous sur la plateforme
alors on dit souvent elisabeth que c'est
une initiative de l'état mais il vous
rappeler qu'en fait ce sont les
complémentaires santé qui avaient été
les premières à vraiment réagir par
rapport à ce sujet dès le printemps 2021
en proposant notamment la prise en
charge de quatre consultations et c'est
que effectivement à partir de fin
septembre que emmanuel macron un peu
repris cela à son compte en proposant
cette fois-ci huit séances
d'accompagnement psychologique le
remboursement de 8 séances alors à
l'entendre comme ça l'idée peut paraître
noble et pourtant pourtant elle est loin
de faire l'unanimité chez les
psychologues pourquoi absolument parce
que d'une part les consultations de ce
type qui sont remboursés par l'assurance
maladie existe déjà notamment au travers
de structures que l'on appelle des
centres médico-psychologiques les fameux
scmp mais que aujourd'hui il manque
énormément de moyens il y a plus de deux
ans de liste d'attenté donc beaucoup de
psychologues estiment que tout cet
argent aurait dû être mis sur des
structures qui existent déjà avec des
professionnels qui sont rodés qui
connaissent bien le système pour déjà
que les structures qu'on est depuis déjà
fonctionné et c'est pour ça que beaucoup
estiment que c'est un une démarche assez
amateur un peu de la poudre aux yeux
autre critique aussi qu'on entend
souvent mon psy et réservé comme je
voulais dit à des patients qui
présentent un trouble léger et modéré
mais c'est vrai que beaucoup de
psychologues nous disent que les
patients qu'ils vont arriver dans leur
cabinet présente plutôt à une grande
détresse psychique poste qu vide alors
pas sûr que ce soit très adapté et c'est
ce qui leur fait dire aujourd'hui que
l'ap 6 et plus de la psychothérapie mais
c'est je cite de l'accompagnement
psychologique low cost qui n'est pas
leur métier alors il faut faut dire que
ç'a vraiment pas un grand succès pour
l'instant puisque sur les vingt-huit
mille psychologue libéraux vous en avez
environ que 1300 qui ont postulé pour
l'instant auprès de l'assurance maladie
autre point épineux c'est évidemment le
tarif de remboursement proposé dans le
cadre de mon psy c'est impossible de
faire des dépassements d'honoraires donc
la première séance va coûter 40 euros et
ensuite ce sera 30 euros ce qui est très
peu quand on sait par exemple qu'un
entretien d'évaluation ça dure environ
45 à 55 minutes et qu'ensuite une séance
de suivi c'est de 30 à 40 minutes et
enfin je finis là dessus le fait d'avoir
une prescription médicale préalable on
sait que ça on a des problèmes on n'a
pas assez de médecins généralistes
notamment dans les campagnes et que donc
ça ça crée un frein à l'accès justement
au psychologue ça oblige aussi le
psychologue à devoir faire un compte
rendu aux médecins généralistes et donc
à ne pas respecter le secret
professionnel alors multipliant les
interlocuteurs ça n'est pas forcément
non plus les et patients à se déclarer
le dispositif il a peut-être été mal
pensé mettre problème lui est bien réel
vous allez me le dire de nombreuses
études aujourd'hui montrent que la santé
mentale des français mais pas que et
largement en train de se dégrader la
faute à quoi la faute aux qu'ovide un
peu non alors la photo co vide entre
autres on sait alors d'une part que le
virus laisse des traces c'est à dire que
chez les personnes certaines études
peuvent le montrer notamment une qualité
qui a été publié le 7 avril dans le lot
7 pjak et ricky montre que quand vous
avez un cas sévère de kobe 19 vous avez
plus de chances de développer et d'être
en proie à des troubles psychologiques
donc ça c'est sûr le côté médical mais
on sait aujourd'hui que tous les toutes
les mesures qui ont été mises en place
notamment confinement les déconfinement
au gré des mois eh bien on crée aussi
beaucoup de détresse psychologique
notamment auprès des jeunes juste pour
vous donner je vais vous citer une une
étude de l'université de zurich en
suisse mais en fait on retrouve à peu
près les mêmes chiffres dans beaucoup de
pays notamment de l' ocde cette étude a
porté sur plus de 1000 jeunes âgés de 12
à 17 ans et leurs parents ainsi que plus
de 1000 adultes de 19 à 24 ans ils ont
constaté deux choses 1 une augmentation
de l'incertitude et de une augmentation
des types de dépression
plus d'un tiers aujourd'hui des jeunes
de 12 à 17 ans ont présenté un problème
de santé mentale c'est absolument énorme
vous avez environ 15% qui ont développé
des symptômes plus particulièrement
d'anxiété ensuite 10% des symptômes de
dépression et 20% des syndromes de ce
qu'on appelle l'hyperactivité avec
déficit de l'attention
c'est entre autres lié aussi au fait que
beaucoup plus de jeunes ont regardé les
écrans pendant les confinements alors ce
qui est intéressant aussi et peut-être
très alarmant c'est selon une étude
cette fois ci en france qui indique ceux
de cos vip rêve qui indique que les
pensées suicidaires sont deux fois plus
élevés aujourd'hui en france par rapport
à 2017 et que la dépression et l'anxiété
ont explosé - pasky tu es là dessus
voilà julien suffisamment anxiogène ce
journal ya des solutions peut-être des
moyens pour essayer de bain en tout cas
oui aujourd'hui c'est sûr que les
psychiatres et les psychologues tire la
sonnette d'alarmé ils disent que si on
devrait être amené à revivre une
pandémie comme celle ci ou en tout cas à
devoir re confiné il faudrait essayer
vraiment de maintenir les routines les
horaires les contacts sociaux est les
activités et que la balance bénéfice
risque encore une fois entre un
confinement et les effets psychologiques
que ça peut avoir sur les enfants
doivent vraiment être réévalués parce
que le fardeau mental qui a été porté
par les jeunes générations depuis plus
de deux ans est bien trop lourd merci
beaucoup je me à singer